[Music]
you go hey you go how's it going man you
okay I'm really well I don't know if you
got my text Timur asked me to give you a
call about your font
yeah excellent
so yeah basically my name is Samuel and
on a property investor so I know but I
know Burton pretty well I live in
Litchfield which is only about maybe
half an hour away so I mean he said that
you're pretty quickly so is there any I
mean okay what's the you go what's you
know what the condition of the property
is is it is it in good bad or average
conditions you know
okay so when have you have you seen the
property for a long time or do you not
seen it for a long time okay and it was
all right and it was okay then so
basically yeah all right so basically
what you're saying is you need to pay
the mortgage off at six to nine thousand
pounds however if you could you know you
could just let the bank have it in which
case you've kind of lost nothing gained
and I think you're just gonna they're
just going to take it off your hands
if you could sell it to someone who was
prepared to give you cash for it
tomorrow for more than sixty nine then
obviously you're gonna have a little bit
of cash which is awesome and then the
investors well I know the area pretty
well and Jim has given me the you know
Jim's giving me the address so I mean
I've done some numbers and stuff I think
the key on this one with with the bank
trying to sell it themselves it's going
to be is going to be speed so I mean if
how what would happen if we worked out a
price which we were both happy with what
would what would happen would we I mean
I obviously might be buying it cash you
know because there's no we haven't got
time to mess around getting a mortgage
and things like that so so what was how
long would the bank give you to complete
on the property if you said if you said
to the bank I found a buyer for it he's
buying it for say I don't know 75 90
whatever we agreed right I've got a
buyer who's buying it how much time
would they give you to complete because
I mean typically
I mean on average it may be two to four
weeks to complete which is very fast but
you see what we could do what we could
do potentially enough to speak to my
solicitor but what we could do is we
could agree a price to buy it from you
but then while it's going what while
it's obviously completing because it can
take a few weeks or so to complete we
could potentially just give you the full
sixty nine thousand pounds in cash and
then you could then pay the mortgage off
but then we have an option to buy the
property in two months - you know
something like that how much how much
cash I mean obviously at the moment you
know the bank is looking at the bank
you're gonna take it off you which is
going to leave you obviously with
nothing how much cash
because it's only fair that okay I mean
how would how would you if I could move
extremely fast how would you be prepared
to go 79 it's just because I mean I know
that you know I'm not trying to be
difficult I buy a lot of properties for
cash so I've got you know I do get good
deals so I mean what would be what would
be the lowest that you could live with
83 that's not a lot that's not a lot dis
carry that's what I usually um how about
I meet you in the middle of 81 and we'll
move tomorrow cash
yeah yeah but obviously that's gonna be
going through the bank and you know you
want money in your you want money in
your oh do we do have a dealer 82 so we
can both be happy sure the thing yeah
the thing is the thing is with me I
won't call you back tomorrow morning
with me you know you can ask channa I've
got a lot of cash in the bank I buy
properties as a professional business
that's what I do so there's no messing
about there's no risk that it's going to
have to end up going back to the bank
I've done this kind of thing before so
you have a think on it and let me know
but if you're happy to go ahead at 82 I
could stretch to 82 and not move fast
professionally and we'd be able to both
have money in our pockets at the end of
the day okay
I'll also you get back to me tomorrow on
the price how can I get into the
property because and what's the best way
of me getting access to the property
yeah neither do I can either do morning
or late afternoon I just can't do any
time between sort of like 12:00 and 3:00
UK time so I can do four o'clock and I
can do
yeah that's fine let me know and yeah
and and and yeah and let me know on a 92
as well let me know if you can do that
and we can get things brought to a very
very quickly
excellent
my name's Samuel yeah some more leads
yeah I mean cheers you know you're
welcome brother soon so there we go I
get so many of those types of calls but
I just figured I'd be called one so let
me know comments below what you learned
[Music]